[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
ask answer your questions about your
life and your money that's right baby
we're going to talk about you right in
front of you the phone number is 8825
5225 the call is free and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it Carlos starts this hour in San
Francisco hey Carlos how are you I'm
doing well how are you thanks for taking
my call sure ma'am what's up exciting
first time calling I have a a question
my wife and I have been saving for a
while we have 20% down for uh a house
here in the Bay Area whoa you got a pile
of money I know that's right right
pretty much it's 1.5 or above uh we also
have a Year's worth of emergency fund uh
you know if I was to uh not be able to
work for a couple of months or whatever
I am the only uh the only income in the
household uh my wife stays at home and U
it's just confusing it's a little scary
I mean we do we have prepared for it but
it's still it's a large amount of money
that the homes we going for out here so
oh yeah um I just wanted to kind of hear
your your guys the device I mean we've
done everything that you have uh asked
of us with the uh baby steps no debt um
two two daughters two and under and uh
we you know we just uh we rent currently
our rent is pretty pretty okay my work
uh pays for a chunk of my rent so it's
even better cool um but we want to grow
our family as well and or we want to
continue growing our family but uh yeah
just uh yeah how old are you question 33
what do you do for a
living um I'm a PG lineman a what
lineman oh okay all right yeah so uh
electric lines build construction yeah
you're making bank you're working your
butt off and you're making bank yeah you
said you already have 20%
saved yeah I work a lot of hours because
my job it's just the work is there it's
just depending how much time am I
willing to trade in for money that's all
it comes down to and that's on top of
that's on top of the years's worth of
expenses you have saved too
right yeah yeah well like I said we
don't have any debt I mean obviously you
have a rent a rent currently is 3 in
your line of work if you're not
respectful of risk careful about risk
you
die correct and so your nature is to
apply that formula to everything else
and so corre you're you you it's okay at
work but you're probably
overanalyzing buying a house
dude I I think so you're not going to
die from it okay so I mean you've done
everything right you've laid the
foundation you've got the money you've
done a really good job you've prepped
the job site so to speak okay yes and so
I there's nothing that you said that
gives me a tilt me neither I wanted to
ask you what's stopping you is there
something else going on that we don't
know about that's stopping you from
pulling the trigger
um no I mean the only thing is my wife
and I are you know I'm pretty pretty
confident about the amount of work that
that is here um every year that I've
been here I've made $100,000 or more in
the last and it's it's it's never ending
work really the only thing that is
taxing is is the the time that I'm away
from home and my wife is concerned that
you know buying a house that's x amount
of dollars would require me to continue
being away from home which it would be
true for obviously we try to get we're
trying to get a 15-year mortgage and our
plan is to pay it off within five to
seven years yeah I think you're on track
you're okay and you can dial back at any
time dial up at any time you've got
always got work you've always got extra
work you're in good shape you're fine uh
and and hey if you do it for a while and
you live in the house three or four
years and you decide oh um we're going
to live somewhere else yeah sell the
house I mean you're going to be fine
it's not like you're going to have
you're sitting in a real estate bubble
in freaking San Francisco I mean it's
going to go up he could it's always gone
up I mean as long as I've been alive and
I'm older than a dinosaur yeah so I mean
it's it has you know you're fine you're
you're sitting in a great Market uh real
estate wise and and you're going to you
know you're going to have a great time
man I think you're I think it's normal
to if you've never done something before
and you're in and you're in a
a career field that causes you to
analyze risk you can get caught up in
paralysis of the analysis sure Ready Aim
aim aim aim aim aim aim aim aim oh pull
the trigger yeah you know seriously and
so you you that's the thing and that I
can do it too anytime any of us can do
that if we get if we're really careful
we're trying to be wise we're trying to
be diligent but you've never done it
before so you don't know what it feels
like and just to step off that diving
board the first time yeah I felt like
that when we bought our first house but
to his wife's point if she feels like
the amount of work that he's doing is
not a normal or sustainable amount of
work over the Long Haul they could
always pull the numbers back and say
well what would it look like this is
more normal or this is what we're hoping
for and they could buy based on those
numbers as opposed to the current
numbers if they wanted that sort of
margin yeah yeah but I mean you're 33
you're going to have you're going to
have more there's going to be another
thing happening with your income later
too and yeah it's okay you're going to
be okay you're going to be just fine so
folks that's why we tell you to do a
15-year fixed where the payment's no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
so you've got some margin in your budget
you've got what economists call
disposable income left in your budget
which allows you to have extra
investment it allows you to have extra
generosity it allows you to have the
margin to create a sustainable work
pattern um and then you can go from that
and say okay I'm going to dial it up for
a little bit knock this puppy out well
let me be the peanut gallery because I
always hear people in the peanut gallery
talking Dave 15E that's not going to
give me more margin that's going to make
my monthly payment go up no it makes
your month and payment exactly the same
it's going to make the amount of house
you buy go down there it is that's what
it's going to be so you don't get the
one with the jacuzzi the Skylight and
the racket ball court you're 24 shut
up okay seriously this that's what it is
it's all about lifestyle okay I grew up
in a th000 ft house one and A2 bath
mhm so don't talk to me about your needs
M okay seriously now you need would be a
shelter right want would be a bigger
shelter right a nicer shelter a shelter
that does things for me automatically oh
man that would be a better
shelter and all of those things are fine
but the need is shelter yeah yeah when
we were when I was uh you know when the
dinosaur little baby dinosaurs were
running around with me when I was a
child we were in this eighth grade we
had the civics class they called it and
they taught us the difference between
needs and
wants food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities are needs
Transportation however is a hoopdee not
a $65,000 F-150 so what you're saying is
that is I want a valid want but it is a
want HGTV doesn't determine what our
needs are yeah they just determine what
you're going to be discontented about
cuz you wish you were them and they live
in an edited world with that's not a
real world I know that's right kind of
like your friends on what do they call
them influencers yeah that's not real
it's not real help you it's not real
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Church Hill gives
you an advantage over those other guys
go to Churchill mortgage.com today to
learn
[Music]
more
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today today's question sponsored
by neighborly your hub for Home Services
neighborly has top quality providers
like Precision Door Service Junk King
and more to help you take care of
projects before the weather gets cold so
find the local help you need by
downloading the neighborly app today
today's question comes from Christa in
Maryland she says my husband and I have
had separate accounts with a joint
account for bills since we've been
married we recently started baby step 2
and purchased every dollar premium I
find that the app has been a GameChanger
but my husband finds it to cause too
much conflict and feels too controlled
with his spending even though he has had
to cut back okay to help this we have
placed a budget item for fund money $100
a month for each of us this is still not
enough into controlling how do I get
through to him that bucking down for a
short amount of time to pay off our debt
is a good thing uh we currently are
122,000 in debt besides our mortgage and
I feel suffocated by this
amount this is a good one um my guess is
you guys have had separate money for a
long time and he's kind of been able to
go and do his Thug Thizzle and not had
to answer to anybody and now you have
the same account and it s I'm just I'm
going off the words on the paper it
sounds like all of this so far has been
your idea and you're getting every
dollar and you're getting the family on
a budget and you're going to put fund
money in the category and you're going
to check it it doesn't sound like this
is a joint effort yet it kind of sounds
like he's there like all right you know
and he's you're kind of having to pull
him along and drag him along yeah you
know why he feels controlled cuz he is
being controlled not by the budget but
by you yeah cuz he's not got a vote in
the process or is not chosen to cast his
vote M she said well here you can have
$100 yeah you're not his mommy yeah
you're his wife so uh yeah you guys he
needs to sit down and say okay the two
of us together have a highdefinition
dream a very clear picture of the future
yep and then we say what must be true to
get there MH and then together we cast a
vote on our money each month on how we
can best get there while still surviving
and having a reasonable life or in some
cases not even a reasonable life but we
chose together to not have one you're
trying to use the budget to whip him
into shape yeah not going to work the wh
the budget is not a whipping post yeah
there's got to be a why behind it it
can't just be we're paying off debt just
to pay off debt for some people that
might work but for most people that's
not going to work there's got to be that
bigger yeah why is why are you doing
this and see he's not he he's like okay
I'll go along instead of like okay let's
sit down honey together yeah you know
because you know like grown man can
choose what he wants to do grown woman
can choose what they want to do with
their money when you sit down and both
of you have a vote yeah and when you
know what the prize is at the end of it
stronger the the stronger the try I'm
going to increase the food the fund
money even though I know it's going to
delay the price you can do that you both
have a vote right I mean you can you can
make an argument for that and but the
the he feels controlled and it has
nothing to do with every dollar
100% yeah it's not every dollar didn't
do it nope nope didn't do it yeah yeah
and by the way if you want to learn
about every dollar and how to build that
budget on that app with your spouse or
as a single either one Jade washaw to my
right and Rachel Cruz and George camel
are periodically doing free webinars at
everydollar.com budgeting on how to
build that out and use it it's
completely free did I mention it is free
if you don't like it we'll give you half
your money back it's free okay so come
on check it out they're you're doing
several of these a month and you can get
signed up for one do you know when your
next one is off top of your I do not
it's in November we'll do two of them
and just to clarify the webinar is free
and you can sign up for every dollar for
free both sides of it is free like free
free indeed it's a lot of free yeah
everydollar.com
budgeting Betty is with us in Denver hi
Betty welcome to the ramsy
show thank you for having me sure how
can we
help um I need to open up a new bank
account and I also need to have a new
apartment both are requiring me to
unlock the freeze on Experian and when I
went online today and went through the
steps and put in my telephone number
they said that that telephone number was
not recognized and that's as far as I
got okay so I'm wondering I guess you're
gonna have to I guess you're gonna have
to call them uh I could not find a
telephone number I tried to Google
search on that and I wasn't able to see
a telephone number for Experian to talk
to someone in customer service they have
a chat room or anything I I've never
tried to I've never tried to unfreeze
mine I I I didn't see any kind of chat
room service come up on anything onl I
don't understand I mean I do understand
an apartment check wanting to check your
credit and yours is Frozen uh but my my
credit has been frozen at nothing on it
it says zero says I filed bankruptcy in
1988 but um here's what I found okay it
says if you have an Experian account you
can unfreeze your credit by logging in
clicking on the help center and then
toggling the free status from unfrozen
to scheduling a new to scheduling a she
tried to log in her it didn't accept her
login because it didn't like her phone
number is that right so I wonder if you
can is that what happened Betty the
login rejected you yeah what if you do
the forgot my password deal
uh I I could try forgot my password I
mean I didn't even I didn't even go to
forgot my
password yeah I would jump in did you
get logged
in uh I I was I was just starting to get
logged in okay yeah um yeah I think you
need to get see if you can get logged in
and if not I would jump on try to find
one of the chat rooms back to what I was
saying before uh Jade so rudely
interrupted me no I'm kidding but the uh
with the with the actual answer to the
question which is problematic but yeah
but the uh the bank account should not
give you trouble I've never unfrozen
mine I've opened hundreds of bank
accounts but now a credit a certain
apartment might want to pay your thing
but my my account has not been unfrozen
since they allowed you to freeze them
some 20s something years ago when they
first came out with that law or that
change in the service that they provide
as a response to Congress breathing down
their neck but yeah yeah that's uh so I
worried about your bank here a little
bit like they think they want to do some
kind of uh overdraft protection debt
thing attached to your checking account
and that's why they want to check your
credit instead of you're just opening an
account yeah so that that's very
possible there and you know I think you
could just tell the uh you know the
apartment complex look here's my job
references here's the down payment or
the deposit and you can't check my
credit because it's frozen the reason
it's frozen is there's nothing on it and
I don't allow goobers like you to mess
around on my Credit Bureau reports so
you want to rent me an apartment or not
otherwise going across the street cuz
there's 73 others that look just like
you around here so uh cuz credit I mean
really the idea that you pull a Credit
Bureau report to rent an apartment is a
little bit unusual yeah yeah it's a lot
yeah so yeah but if you want to get it
unfrozen it sounds like you need to get
a login process I have not done it to
answer your question Betty so I'm not
sure but but um I mean this is what it
says on their site so I think she just
needs to go one step like follow the
steps through going a little bit deeper
and
then yeah see if it won't see if you
can't get past the phone number
thing Edward is in New York City hi
Edward welcome to the Ramsey
Show hello Dave Jade good afternoon how
you guys doing how can we help all right
um so basically quick story married you
know six years two kids five and two um
no student loan debt but we do find
ourselves in about 114,000 of Consumer
Debt um that's how was KN out in the
house um total take home roughly the
month is about
9600 um I'm just trying to yeah what's
the what's the 110 114 without student
loans about you got big cars what's the
deal it's it's two cars uh one of them
is about 13,000 the other one's about 23
uh two personal loans of one was a debt
consolidation before we bought the
house um I basically we basically were
debt free when we sold the house uh we
paid everything off and then little by
little everything crept up within the
past 3 and a half years so it's now it's
just at a scary point that I'm going
down a road that I don't want to go down
um we need a behavior change figure out
yeah I think you've identified what the
problem is the cars aren't the problem
36,000 out of 114 you got something else
going on here it sounds like you guys
have tried to borrow your way out of
debt with these debt consolidation loans
and didn't change your habits so hang on
we'll set you up with every dollar and
put you through financial pece
University so you can get a game plan
going to either start shedding yourself
of stuff certainly shedding yourself of
Lifestyle to get down under your income
and start really turning this thing
[Music]
[Applause]
around hey folks Dr John delone here
with some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time they become Healthy
Habits Like choosing to slow down and
make time for a daily practice of prayer
and meditation one thing that has helped
me with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you three months free to
get started that's 3 months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Pao has given you 90 days
free imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hall.com
Ramsey today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Jade was allw Ramsey personality my
co-host today I'm Dave Ramsey your host
Jan's with us in Jackson New Hampshire
hi Joanie how are
you well as you say better than they
deserve much better good how can we help
today well and my dad used to say advice
is wor what you pay for it so that was
fun to start the show off with that okay
so I uh my daughter's two 40ish years
old daughters and I co-own a cabin
that's uh across the road from my house
where I I've lived at this house for 40
years and um we bought the cabin five
years ago we all three on the deed and
as he said a few weeks ago never go into
business with anyone one reason being
that they will have different
interests from you and that's what we're
facing um I'd like to move from my home
to the cabin um which needs some serious
work to make it
livable um and my daughters one of them
wants to just do as little as possible
and make it into a seasonal
rental and the other one wants that also
but she doesn't want me to have a home
there CU she can deny
uh because we all have to agree since
we're
co-owners um we all have to agree on
work done there and about 20 years ago
she was doing a bunch of bad stuff and I
had told her if you keep this St you're
going to have to leave so I had to kick
her out of the house and she wants to
punish me for that so the way you the
way you hand that she you have a
daughter that wants to punish you and
you decide to buy a cabin with her
it wasn't um it
wasn't bought the cabin five years ago
20 years ago you kicked her
out well five years ago when the cabin
came up for sale um the
owner wanted to sell it to my
daughters and so they on paper bought it
I paid $200,000 for it um so I paid for
the taxes and the purchase price and all
of the repairs that we have done um so
they put no money in Money
in excuse me they put no money
in right oh gosh and I bought my house
you and do you guys have any kind of
written agreement on this at
all we have one agreement that they came
up with that says we all have to agree
on any work that's done did you sign
that yes
why
why did you I don't know I don't know
why you did any of this if you had
$200,000 buy the cabin don't buy the
cabin why did you put them on here
knowing that this is going to be that
this one daughter is going to be a
problem from day one I didn't I didn't
know that and that yeah you did would
not sell it to me alone she wanted to
sell it to my daughters why so I had no
we either wouldn't get the cabin yeah or
the girls would both be on the de what
was initially the use of the cabin when
you first bought it did you buy it cuz
you said you know what I'm going to move
in here and everybody knew that or was
the initial purpose of the cabin to rent
it out to someone someone
else it was me moving up there was an
option um we didn't talk about any plans
I started doing little bits here and
there having a cabin chinked making sure
the roof was good okay joh let me ask
you this how how old are you I bought it
to I bought it to protect the value of
my house um so that we're surrounded by
national forest and it's I bought my
house for
$289,000 now it's worth a million Joanie
how old are
you 70 70 okay you have made a
mess that's right this is a mess okay
and you're really left with only a
couple of options uh one is to convince
your daughters to deed the property over
to you given that they put no money in
it to start with and they have no rights
to this morally or ethically MH okay
this is an absurd deal you should not
have done this deal it was a dumb deal
it was a bad deal you set yourself up to
get punched in the nose now you're
getting punched in the nose so now the
only thing you can do with this is you
can convince them to deed it over to you
or you can hire an attorney and sue them
and force the sale of the cabin
and show the judge that they put zero
dollars into this and that at least you
get your $200,000 back before there's
anything split at the sale now you get
to decide are are you going to be able
to convince them that you guys are all
stupid what you've done here is all
stupid you're not stupid but what you've
done is
ridiculous it's a horrible plan and your
daughters are horrible that they took a
third of this
knowing that they didn't get along with
their 70-year-old mother and she paid
100% of it that's kind of like being a
thief okay that's kind of what that's
like so I don't really like your
daughters much and this is not going to
be easy and so I don't know that you're
going to be able to convince these two
dweebs to turn the thing over to you and
I'm afraid you're going to be faced with
a judge to do it or you've just gotten
screwed out of 200,000 cuz you've lost
control of this cuz you've got a two to
one vote and the deed does doesn't have
any restrictions on it whatsoever you've
got three people and they have two of
the
votes so uh but a judge can untangle
this and the a judge can force the sale
of the of of the cabin and give you
$200,000 at the sale one other option on
the persuasion side you could do is you
can offer the dweeb some money to go
away I'll give you $25,000 a piece if
you've got it or whatever to sign the
deed over to me gosh
which is immoral yeah thievery blackmail
whatever you want to call it but you
it's going to be cheaper than Court mhm
she's not going to like them much after
that though well I don't like them so
it's easy to not like them yeah I mean
they're not likable that's right who
does this to their parents oh I don't
know it's weird you threw me out of the
house 20 years ago so I'm going to get
back at you I'm going to get you to pay
full price for a cabin that I own
onethird of and then I'm not going to
let you do anything good God this is
terrible year old is this needs
counseling unbelievable so yeah some
people's children but the um yeah guys
you cannot enter into these things wide
eyed open and expect you know a
crocodile to do anything but bite your
leg off crocodiles is what they do I
just can't understand the I even even if
they liked each other right what would
be ever the purpose of going into
something like it it makes no sense if
she was going to move into it anyway
just buy the house for herself well the
guy wouldn't sell it to her which is
weird that's weird too there's a lot of
weird here but yeah uh Johnny I'm sorry
I wish I had a magic wand to make your
pain go away but your pain is not a
cabin your pain is your daughter's mhm
and that's what you're going to have to
deal with one way or another probably
the cheapest way to do this is just buy
the dweebs out and get them to sign it
over just you know it's a dweeb fee it's
a stupid tax fee and I do something
stupid and that cost me money Johnny I
call it stupid tax you're probably going
to pay pay some stupid tax here you are
going to pay some stupid tax they better
they better not ask for a third you're
going to pay a lawyer well they'll ask
for it you know these D well so you're
going to either pay a lawyer you're
going to pay the dweebs or you're going
to lose your 200,000 these are your
three way you're but you're going to
lose money you're going to lose money
something something's going on here I'm
paying a lawyer that if if it's me I'm
paying a lawyer I don't I don't want to
fool with these girls anymore wow it's
your kids they're
dweebs to quote a well-known
philosopher oh man oh that's terrible I
feel bad but you know I was doing a
thing with some wealthy people the other
day and they were all worried they were
saying you know how do I raise my
children when we have wealth and the
wealth doesn't ruin them and I told them
I said the wealth won't ruin them it's
just going to exposed if you did if you
ruined them the wealth's just going to
give you the exposure to that it's going
to magnify cuz whatever goes on that's
uh in a family is is magnified when it
gets wealth wow in other words the crazy
gets super crazy mhm right the uh but I
mean this is all tied to you know
$200,000 worth of thievery here Joy I am
so sorry your heart must be broken
mine's broken for you I'm angry for you
I just can't do anything about it except
Ray all about it y this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsay we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we use to optimize and take
us to the next level netweek gave us the
visibility into all of our numbers so
that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with us net week
worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
Nets to help make them smarter and make
better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
Jessica is with us in Salt Lake City hi
Jessica how are you I'm good how are you
better than I deserve what's
up hi so I have a couple months left in
baby step three but I'm just trying to
decide what to prioritize after that
because I really want to buy a house but
I also really want to catch up in my
retirement savings and I also really
want to do grad school so that I can
raise my income so that I could do both
of those other things faster uh grad
school in
what it's in education so I'm a teacher
and if I get a grad school then I get a
pay bump all automatic yeah it's built
into the system yeah yeah okay and how
long will it take you to complete grad
school about a year maybe two years if I
go slow I'm going to be doing it
online what's it
cost it costs 4 ,000 per six months so
hopefully I'll keep it under
10,000 okay like if you did in one year
that' be eight if you did in one year
and a half it'd be 12 right right right
okay all right so and then I'm hoping
that I can um I forgot what I was about
to say are you
single yes I'm what's your income kids
uh right now it's 57,000 okay all right
and the so do we do we put 12 towards
what's the pay bump on the uh after you
get your grad level
done it it'll be about five or 10
thousand okay five or
10 well between because the salary
schedules are little bit different
depending on how long you've been
teaching it's it's most of them are
about
7,000 well I mean you know how long
you've been teaching how much B pay bump
will you
get well I don't know I don't know next
year's salary schedule if that makes
sense it does not change five or $10,000
every year though I mean what was it
what would it be if it was this year it'
be 7,000 for you okay all right so you
get your money back in a year and a half
and from then on you got an extra $7,000
that's a pretty good deal and if that
delays you buying a house a little bit
I'm cool with
that okay but that also makes me want to
get that also makes me want to get
through school super fast I know yeah
and then do I contribute to retirement
during that or do I just go as fast as I
can through that and then through well
can can you cash flow school and do
retirement yes well let's do that I
would do that yeah let's do that and
then if you want if if you get out and
you get your 7,000 bump and you want to
start saving for a house you want to
turn off retirement for one year while
you uh save for a house or something
that'd be okay but you could turn it on
for right now and get some started right
yes love it but I think the trick is the
faster you finish school two things
happen to the math one is they're no
longer charging you four grand every 6
months and that much faster you get
7,000 other words you finish school in
one year it makes you an extra 7,000
versus finishing it in two
years right and it saves you another
8,000 in
tuition yes so I'm doing this in a
year okay I mean if I can figure out any
way that's sustainable and pull that off
I mean that that's interesting to me
it's not the cost is not based on the
load of classes she's taking C you can
only take but yeah it is but it's not a
per class in this she's buying she's
buying a program just the the package
she's buying she's buying a degree and
the degree cost X and soon how fast can
you get through it and you got to sign
up for a minimum number got it but um I
mean if you take classes
in in traditional brick and mortar and
you pay the T the quarterly or the
annual or I'm sorry the semester tuition
um you can take you know 10 hours or 15
hours it's the
same doesn't change at most most schools
it doesn't Okay so that's that's the way
that's coming off Natalie is in
Cincinnati hi Natalie how are you good
how are you better than I deserve what's
up so I am trying to figure out how to
purchase my next home if I should go
ahead and um try to get a conventional
loan myself or get a conventional loan
together with my fiance or if I would
even qualify for an
FHA an FHA
why well I've never owned a okay so I
own a home because I um got a quit feed
from my grandparents who pass me their
home um but I they never had any um
loans on it it was already paid off
what's wrong with that what's wrong with
that
house it's just small my family's out
growing it and it's in a very bad school
district you have kids how many kids you
have yes I have two kids you have two
kids how old are your
kiddos um three and three months how
long have you had Granny's
house um almost six years now
three-year-old's not in
school correct oh the six not six months
did you say six months or six
years um six years I've had the house no
I'm sorry the children are how old oh
three years old and three months old
yeah neither one of them have a school
district
problem not yet and the the the kids are
these the fiance's
kids yes okay oh I see I'm just putting
putting the pieces of the puzzle
together now the mystery comes clear
good catch okay so when are you getting
married um hopefully whenever we go to a
courthouse we don't have a date set open
to just going whenever it's open
today okay congratulations do not number
one do not buy a home with someone that
you do not have that you are not legally
married to
mhm you will get yourself into a pinch
all kinds of problems and do not just do
not do that so you need to get married
and then buy a house what I would do if
I were in your shoes listening to this
is I would get married and I would live
in Granny's house M cuz neither one of
these kids have a school district
problem when things unfold over the next
two or three years and you want to start
talking about moving will sell Granny's
house and the combined income of the two
of you plus the down payment coming from
Granny's house will be the purchase of
your next house in a better school
district but you do not need to buy a
house before you're married you do not
need to buy a house after you're married
right now what's Granny's house worth
I'm just
curious I think we could sell it for
about
200,000 there you go that's no slouch no
it's not this is not a shack yeah no
okay it's it's just it's it's small for
us um and like I said with the school
district we we have an opportunity get a
house that's not on the market yet
coming up soon in a school district we
really like and so sorry you're not
ready tried there will be more
opportunities there'll be more opport
you don't need to buy a school district
for a three
yearold okay you just got you got house
fever here and and this new found
responsibility of stepmother ship is
carrying a burden for you and you're
trying to do the right thing and be a
good mom and I appreciate that that's
smart of you thank you for that but um
but you got time you got time you'll get
there if I were use I would just get
married and uh live in Granny's house
for a while and then when we get ready
to move later we'll work on finding the
right deal in the right School District
at the right price and sell Granny's
house for the down payment and the two
of you now have a nice combined income
you will not need an FHA loan you'll get
a conventional loan with the two of you
an FHA loan usually the only reason
anybody ever does that is they just
don't have any down payment hardly yeah
they don't have anything saved and so
you don't need to do that now I think
what's happened is this one particular
house popped up and the fever set in and
now we're trying to figure out a way to
back end the deal yeah that is the fever
that's the thing you know sometimes when
you're in a moment you think if this
moment passes it'll never happen again
and it's like you're right it won't that
moment won't happen again but whoop dupy
yeah something else will happen that'll
be just as good there's a stinking house
on every corner they're everywhere
there's only one house now no there's n
there's a lot of them I've owned a lot
of them I've lived in a lot of them it's
just a house you'll get you another one
it's it's you know this this my forever
no it's not it's not your Forever house
that's a joke you're not going to be
there forever that's dumb so Dave the
interest rates went past 8% they did
yeah
yay don't say yay it's
awesome finally there's going to be some
Bargains in the real estate market again
I was ready for I didn't seen Bargains
in like a decade man I'm ready for some
real estate Bargains Dave you just
pissed off all those people you don't
care hey it's not going to you're not
it's not going to be 8% forever no it's
not Ian we're going into an election
cycle do you think the Democrats won
High interest rates that's how you lose
the White House okay come on facts think
facts the number of sitting presidents
that survive a bad economy and high
interest rates for housing and get
reelected is really close to zero okay
you just can't find that in history so I
think next year is going to be really
exciting I do too o this is the Ramsey
[Music]
sh hey what's up guys it's Jade if you
love the show and want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it's the ramsy show we
help people build wealth do work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today I'm Dave
Ramsey the phone number is
88255 225 Jeff's in Indianapolis hi Jeff
welcome to the Ramsey Show hi Dave
pleasure to talk with you you too what's
up my wife and I are in our early 70s uh
my son lives about a mile from us he's
in his early 40s he relocated back here
to Indiana from California about 11
years ago from La where he was working
in the music business and uh he was
going to take over my insurance agency a
few years uh retired about nine years
ago so he did take that over um he got
into tax problems when he was in
California because he was working for a
music composer that actually treated him
as an employee but paid him as an
independent contractor so he didn't know
anything about paying taxes got behind
with the state and the IRS end up owing
them
uh 30 or 40 Grand I think we helped him
work out a structured repayment plan as
a condition to him coming back and
getting into insurance and that's been
paid through wage garnishments uh since
then I discussed with him before he came
back to need to stay on top of his taxes
and finances because he's never been
good with money during that period of
time many times I'd ask him if he was on
this and he' just blow up and wouldn't
talk to me about it three months ago he
called us and told us that he was in tax
debt to the IRS again and wanted his mom
and I to uh bail him out basically using
our share of his of of our estate when
we die uh we thought he'd probably owe
about 50 or $660,000 turns out he hasn't
filed any state or federal tax returns
for the past four years nor has he paid
any estimated taxes for
2023 we're meeting with our accountant
next Thursday to go over all this to get
specific numbers but I'm guessing from
what I've seen it's going to be over
$200,000 and about half of that is just
interest and penalties he also hasn't
paid any 941 withholding or state
unemployment tax he has no business
being self-employed obviously so my
question is uh we have the assets to do
that but we would have to sell off
property and mutual funds we our in I
don't know if you need our income or
what exactly what's your net
worth net worth probably about 2.3
million and about 80 about uh roughly
half of that is in two pieces of real
estate our residents here in Indiana and
another home we own in Florida I'm sorry
Jee 80 including the including the real
estate uh the majority of our assets are
in IRA rths and 403bs from where my my
wife taught we've got about 4,000 what
does he make what's his income at the
insurance
company well he just resigned from that
position because after he took it over
he ran it into the ground and couldn't
make a go of it right now he's doing a
sales job and uh it seems to be going
pretty well but he's only been doing it
a couple of months he's making about uh
75,000 a year plus
bonuses is he is he
married he's not married he has an
eight-year-old granddaughter that we
absolutely love and uh spends a lot of
time with us uh he got he he uh was
going to get married but they did it
kind of reverse they got pregnant first
and then they they didn't get along so
they didn't get married so both of them
are here in town and both of them are
have jobs and our own businesses and
they they get along fine we we all get
along fine the insurance agency was
yours and you sold it or gave it to him
it was I actually worked for a captive
company so they actually owned it and
when I left they paid me a percentage of
my renewals and that's one one of the
cornerstones of my retirement now so I
didn't have a say in where so so you had
a book of business but what did he come
into he he didn't take over your book
did he he did pretty not all of it
because they gave some they split it was
a big agency so they split it up among
other agents they gave him about half of
it okay and he ran your book into the
ground okay ran into the ground okay
Jeff does he have any other debt besides
the tax debt that you know of do you
know what that number looks like I don't
think he owes he he rents he doesn't own
a home I don't think he owes anything
else he doesn't have credit card debts
the tax debts the only one I'm that I'm
aware
of I hear your
disgust for his behavior in your voice
and I also hear I also hear a dad that
loves his son even though he's been
stupid you hear very well
um so I guess there's two options one is
you bail him out which doesn't sound
real
appealing um if you don't bail him out
what happens he just has to work with
the IRS and for a lot of years and yeah
actually grow up yeah we got the thing
is Dave this this has happened so many
times I can't count them but you've been
there to bail them out every time yeah
and we we had take him out of high
school because of his behavior we had to
sent him out to a a survival camp in
Idaho then we put him in a private
school in California and all that
required a second mortgage on our house
at the time uh we bailed him out of a
car loan that he didn't keep up with
that I co-signed for uh it's just been
one thing after another he just is I'm
I'm okay with no being the answer yeah I
if it were me I wouldn't do it here's
here's here's what what I'm gonna here's
what I'm going to
suggest he got a he got a severance
package from the insurance company
that's going to pay out about 30 grand
over the next five years about 6,000 a
year I told him that we would help him
out if he would sign that over to me to
pay back what we're going to advance him
but I initially thought we could do the
whole amount I don't think you should do
any of that Jee I really don't that's
the way I think that's the way I think I
think that he's grown and I think that
he makes a living it's he's not making
he's not poverty level there's nothing
wrong with him I think he just needs to
be a man and do man
things I totally agree with you and I
think you're a great
dad thank you you there's one other one
other question that kind of take us out
a little further because I don't think
my son realizes how bad of pos position
he's in if he pays this over the next 20
or 30 years he still may not have it
paid off and we die and that's all right
we may yeah but we have we have all of
our all of our assets and our our our
real estate is in trust and my daughter
is the trustee and the executive and we
Cur we currently put a clause in our
will that that allowed my son to take
our house here as part of his settlement
of the estate because he loves our home
but I'm concerned that if he doesn't
have this paid off I don't even know
that I want to leave leave that share of
the estate to him because I think the
IRS could put a lean on that they can
and after after he becomes the owner
they can yeah yeah and I want to make
sure that I mean ultimately it was for
him but it's ultimately also to go to
our granddaughter and I don't want to
eat up our share of that estate I think
you can I think these are two separate
questions do you help him today they are
yeah do you help him today Jade and I
are both saying sadly I probably
wouldn't I probably wouldn't that's the
way I'm thinking and then uh do I change
the D change the will uh in a few years
I might you can change it now you can
change it later can you put something in
there that says if the debts not paid
off the home goes elsewhere until the
debt is paid off you could leave an
interest for the granddaughter and
bypass it bypass the
the kid they can't seem to find his way
yeah that's so sad this is the ramsy
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something is
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and and
their team is ready to help with
everything from design consultation to
measuring and installation plus there
are never any misleading quotes or
hidden fees everything's backed by their
100% satisfaction guarantee and shipping
is always free Cy blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 40% off that's blinds.com
rules and restrictions May
[Music]
apply hey guys if you like this show you
can help us if you don't like this show
what are you listening
for if you like the show you can help us
we would appreciate it click the
Subscribe button the follow button
whether you're a YouTube follower a
podcast click click the appropriate
button it changes the algorithm and
pushes the show forward and lets people
that don't know about it know about it
thank you for doing that you can also
share the show some show some of the
platforms have a share button others are
you're just listening on talk radio and
you say hey I listen to such and such a
station the ramsy shows on there tell
people about that sharing you need to
share click the share button share a
link whatever it is do all that leave a
festar review that says we love ramsy
you guys are our marketing plan we don't
own a football stadium
like sorry about that yeah and uh yeah
we we you know we don't have $300
million dollars to put into uh marketing
around here so you guys are it if you
want this show and this whole movement
to grow spread the word baby thank you
all right Dan's in Chicago hi Dan how
are you I too too bad how about yourself
better than I deserve what's
up I have a question I've been listening
to you for uh probably about four or
five months now and you're probably
going to yell at me but I have several
Whole Life
policies and after listening to you um
and doing a lot of research um come to
realize how poor of an investment this
is sorry it's not an investment an
expense um but wondering if we do decide
to cancel our policies what we should do
uh whether we should leave the policies
in place and just keep the lower death
benefit or if we should take the cash
render value and invest that someplace
else first thing you do is make sure you
have the proper amount of life insurance
in place and term life insurance go to
an indep go to an independent broker
somebody Alexander and get the best
possible price on that once that's in
place we can talk about cancelling these
and then I would cancel them
completely I'm not sort of playing with
rattlesnakes right yeah I've already
I've already gone on to the Xander and
have several uh quotes so I'm just
looking at the best one yeah um ready to
get that in place and then like I said
she then just cancel it just cancel it
and it'll drop it'll drop some cash
value into your hand and then wherever
you are on the baby steps you'll take
that cash value and Advance your baby
steps how much money do you think it'll
be uh it will be
roughly 115,000 in cash runer value
fabulous where are you in the baby
steps uh we're well we're Step St and
paying off the house was paid off
whatever sorry step sticks okay you your
home off early next year uh roughly
200,000 okay all right so this this this
will just advance that then okay and is
there any is I I thought I read
someplace that there is a time frame
where you have to have a policy you have
to have a policy in place for a certain
number of years before you can take the
cash render value out otherwise you get
hit with a balty is that accurate No No
your basis in a whole life policy is is
what you've put into it and anything you
take out that's more than that is a gain
but very seldom do you get more out than
you put in because the fees are so high
and it's such a horrible product so you
actually you actually lose money almost
every time so it's not a tax not a
taxable event right yeah we have lost
money up to this point which is
frustrating I'm glad I started listening
to you guys um I'm curious how much have
you put
in uh roughly
170 yeah wow and 115 out yeah wow y yeah
that that's that's so that you know if
you you you don't have you do not have a
taxable event period it's not a there's
no because it's not it's not an
investment so it's not you don't
approach it like a gain if you if you
had a capital gain investment if you've
not owned it one year capital gains
don't apply ordinary incomes apply
applies but this is not an investment so
it doesn't come that does not come up if
you bought a whole life policy this year
and you cashed it out this year capital
gains calculation does not apply to that
it's simply your basis is what you paid
for it are you getting out more or less
than what you paid in that's the simple
calculation on the taxes so you're fine
you're fine you're not going to be taxes
you're not fine but you're not going be
taxes no he's not fine he he lost a lot
of money it's so sad it's a horrible
thing Eli is in Little Rock Arkansas hi
Eli how are you hi David Jade it's an
honor to talk to you how are youall
better than we deserve what's up yeah so
I just had a quick question um my wife
and I have a vehicle uh that is a
$20,000 car loan uh we are in baby step
number two we have our thousand um you
know uh safety net and everything um my
question is about the vehicle um all we
what we have is we have $20,000 in
student loans to pay off and we have the
vehicle which has a $20,000 note on it
the payment per month is
$355 we make we make between 6,000 and
7,000 a month um we're both in education
so my question is what to do with that
vehicle um we can afford the payment you
know obviously we can pay it off or I
know Dave I know you hate brand new cars
we did buy the car brand new um but that
was before we really started with this
whole process yeah that that's not
that's their next purchase we worry
about that now we so the way we look at
cars is two things if all of the things
you own that have wheels and
Motors um added up equals less than half
your annual income you're okay this this
one is do you have an expensive car in
the second car no sir our second car
there's there's no note on it I'm asking
what its value is oh the value the value
of that car I've blue booked it it's
it's around1 19,000 okay so you got
$40,000 worth of vehicles you make
$85,000 a year so you know you're about
half you know you don't need to buy
anything else with a dad gum motor I can
tell you
that are we're definitely not we're not
going in any deeper that's a fact the uh
then the second thing is can I be debt
free other than the house baby step two
in two years or less can you pay off
$40,000 in two years or less I believe
so yes sir I think you can too so if you
want to struggle through and keep the
car you can if you want to move down in
car and accelerate this process by about
6 months you could do that but um that
you know but I think you got two years
of plowing through $40,000 worth of debt
making 80 yeah all right what do you
think you'll do I'd probably plow plow
through what are you going to do I I
think we'll plow through um we have we
have two small children um and um you
know it's kind of the the car it's it's
a great car it's been a great car for us
we have no issues with it I just I'm to
that point where I'm just like oh I just
want to get done with this you know um
but I I think that if we were to we were
if we were to sell it we would take a
little bit of a hit yeah um and I I
ultimately think that we would be in the
situation where we'd be looking for
something it needs to be my wife and I
both live we live about three hours from
our family um so we we take quite a few
little trips to see our parents and
things like that so we we need some we
want something reliable but you know I'm
just I wanted your input I figured I
mean you know you need to get that every
dollar budget dialed in and crank that
lifestyle down yeah get that Crank that
lifestyle down and you got to be at a
$2,000 month burn rate yeah and you
might be able to crank it up and keep
the car by adding more income in I mean
are you guys doing anything extra to
bring an income not at this moment um I
know it sounds kind of funny but we
actually have in the past we've donated
plasma we have a plasma center right
down the road um and you wouldn't
believe how much people pay for plasma I
hear not as much as they'll pay you to
tutor no you're right about that you're
right about that and there's no needles
involved
yeah shouldn't be in theory
anyway that's funny yuck look people are
out here giving plasma and making a
$100 I don't know per vial I don't know
how they do it but I'm like H I'd rather
deliver pizzas yeah I think I think I
think I'm well
yeah so guys here's the deal the car I
love cars I'm just a boy I like cars
with big mufflers and Loud engines I'm a
redneck boy so I'm I'm All About cars
but here's the thing it's the largest
thing that you and I buy that goes down
in
value and then the average new car loses
60 to 70% of its value in the first 3
years ouch that means you're turning
$30,000 into
$122,000 and then scratching your head
and wondering why you're broke see what
you ought to do if you're driving one of
those things you ought to roll down the
window and just throw $100 bills out as
you're going down the road cuz that's
basically what's
happening and so if you're driving a
$50,000 car and you make
$60,000 you're broke people and you're
always going to be broke people cuz you
have too much of
your mathematical juice tied up in
something that's going down in value wow
and I love cars I get it I get the fever
I understand but it's the dumbest thing
we do with money you guys it's
particularly a middle class dumb thing
to do this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
Jade washaw Ramsey personality my
co-host today thank you for being with
us Caitlyn is in Milwaukee Wisconsin hi
Caitlyn how are you good how are you
better than I deserve what's up um so I
guess to get short with it I need to
figure out how
to essentially get my spouse he is
mentally on board with me but not
physically on board with me in not just
baby steps but Financial aspects in
general he has a bit of a addiction with
uh um instant
[Music]
gratification
okay
um it's not an addiction it's not an
addiction it's just immaturity um very
good point yes how old is he um he is
the same age as me he's 32 okay how does
that manifest what does it look like his
spending we'll put it in addiction for
quotes right now sure um so he is pretty
he's got a little bit better I'll give
him that credit but he is pretty selfish
um some examples are instead of I mean
the family car was a decent family car
one that that fits the kids we out
unfortunately outgrew it not to him
knowing um but then he instead of just
leaving it as a daily he needed to um
lower it which makes it more expensive
and ruins the car more then he needed to
buy a customized steering wheel that
absolutely wasn't needed then he needed
to do this and he knew that um he souped
up your family minivan wow so not the
minivan it was a wagon it was his daily
that would still fit us at the time not
anymore but at the time would fit all of
us and then I had like a daily
um that was at all of us and is he
creating debt while doing this oh I
can't even argue I can't even like
fathom the amount like being a person
that before I met him I bought my own
house as a single mom it completely
destroys me like I I I have so much
stress from everything he's done
actually the last year I spent curing
like stress
seizures wow okay um you said you had
children how
many um we had three children M um one
of them is not biologically his but he
since day one has taken care of her like
he is his she is his excuse me okay all
right well I I this is not a money
problem it's not a budget problem this
is a marriage it's a marriage problem
and so uh we end up backing into those
sometimes through budgeting and that
kind of stuff but there's budgets don't
control people people control budgets or
don't or in some cases don't do a budget
or in some cases don't live with a
budget but budgets aren't they don't
have any magic powers it's just simply a
road map maps don't control people you
just look at the road map and am I going
to go down am I going to go down the
road or not you know that's all a budget
is it's just a map and so um and and
wives don't control husbands and
husbands don't control wives yeah as
much as they'd like to and as much as it
would be awesome if we could pull it off
we just can't do it um and so what we've
got here is as you said I you know
selfish and immature guy who's putting
his own impulses ahead of the good of
his family have uh have you guys reached
out to a counselor that's what you need
yeah yes so we've done marriage
counseling already um that I set up that
then he denied marriage counseling when
he was ready no I know so we've done
these things because that's where it's
led to um I've
also he went two times to when I set up
and then he denied going cuz he was
essentially being blamed for things and
he didn't like it he was getting
defensive and it's like well not saying
that I'm perfect but you know your
selfish habits are creating an issue
yeah um then he set up marriage
counseling he also more recently is
going back to therapy for himself few
years ago but he is going now um and now
he is seeing a and I don't remember the
difference between psychiatrist and
psychologist but technically I guess
seeing both
so so he's got a lot of stuff going on
huh unfortunately yes um yeah the first
thing you said when you said hey we went
to counseling he didn't like my
counselor because this and that I will
say both spouses need to feel good with
the counselor because you know Sam and I
you know we we've gone to counselors and
it's been like I don't like her or I
didn't like him and you do sometimes
have to but if you don't like them
because they're telling you the truth
that's a problem yeah that is a problem
yes and he also didn't like that the guy
get his name right a couple times which
I won't argue you know whatever but um
but yeah it it was mostly because of
he's telling him the truth and he
doesn't want to hear it yeah that's most
so he is going and he is going for
himself uh that's good I think the hard
part with this
is this is not necessarily going to be
mean that next week things are different
right like this is something that's
going to play out over time um and he's
still actively creating debt for your
family at this moment in time right or
no un unfortunately yes even though we
try to work out things that you know
give
him leniency isn't really the word
um if he's if he's running these things
up on credit cards is your name on the
credit card or is it just these are
cards that he's pulling out and he's
doing this on his own so he he had like
one in my name that he put in the
collections that then I paid off because
I was also on it trying to help him
build credit from when we first got
married okay and that one's closed yep
and that that one's closed um he did
have he's got three of his own he hasn't
touched credit cards in a couple years
and then he um then I you know he we
kind of discussed how we're going to
make things work and I asked if he was
ready and so he got a $300 limit back um
like two weeks ago and he racked that up
plus he had $100 cash um so he spent
$400 about five
days so I took the credit card away I
was like you clearly aren't ready you
told me you were ready I think I think
think as a rule of thumb in your family
in general you need to cut up all the
credit cards and no one uses them no one
uses any more credit cards so that's
thing one is we just don't operate on
debt anymore I mean my screen says that
you know if you're in in in the trying
to do the baby steps like you definitely
cannot use credit cards anymore so those
get cut up and then after that yeah you
probably do need to have a really a real
conversation about how his access is to
this money if he's just going to go off
and spend $5 and $600 I mean that is
that's a scary position to be in Dave
Kaitlin at some point through you
working with the counselor or working
and or working with his counselor the
day is going to come and it's coming
pretty soon based on the tone of your
voice that you're finally going to say
something
like if we can't get on the same page
with money and you can't be a grown man
and take care of your family instead of
buying freaking steering
wheels then I'm not going to be able to
be here
anymore because you're terrifying
me I am awake at night I've never been
in debt like this your out of control
childish behavior with money is
terrifying
me I can't live like this so if you
can't be a grown
man and learn to control your impulses
you're not a 12 12-y old little boy
you're acting like one but if you can't
be a grown man and we can't get a a a
bead on we're going to manage our income
together for the good of this family
that will include you doing some fun
things and me doing some fun things but
it's going to include being a freaking
responsible grownup yeah and if we can't
get to that point I'm not going to be
able to be here MH and you need the
guidance of a good counselor on how to
say say that and when to say that I'm
not suggesting you hang up the phone and
say Dave Ramsey said that sure but I'm
telling you if you do not get there
systematically and begin to put that in
front of him one day here's what's going
to happen and I know this because I've
counseled thousands of
couples you're going to have that little
switch that particularly ladies have
down inside them and it's going to blow
a
fuse and you're going to be done and no
amount of talking and no amount of
coning and no amount of logic and no
amount of preachers and no amount of
nothing is going to get you back in the
marriage you're going to wave
bye-bye cuz you're going to blow a
gasket and you will have had it and I've
tried to reel these ladies back in after
they've blown it and show them that the
guy gave he gave in he gave in too late
she's gone all you see is her back
walking away she's done you wait you
just kept on you kept on you kept on you
kept on until she blows a freaking
gasket and you're it's in your voice I
can hear it so you need to keep away
from that gasket Blowing by getting some
coaching on how to bring him to bear
before you don't care if he comes to
Bear anymore this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places want won't touch and gives
you a custom loan built for you based on
your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumps some payoff op option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
5225 the number one cause of divorce in
North America today is money fights and
money
problems the number one barrier to
Building Wealth
is not being on the same page not
working together we found in the data
when we studied millionaires this is
data not your
feelings not your broke brother-in-law's
opinion not some on Tik Tok who's
an influencer but actual
data that
87% of the millionaires say one of the
key reasons they were able to build
wealth was they were a able to work
together as a team with their spouse
yeah proverbs 31 says who can find a
virtuous wife for her worth is far above
rubies the heart of her husband safely
trusts her and he will have no lack of
gain I like that phrase No Lack of gain
I want some of that no lack of gain
thing and so that means I get to listen
to my virtuous wife if you is a wife and
you is virtuous that means you don't
think you're the Holy Spirit you think
you're the
wife you're not in
charge but you have common sense as my
wife says all the time she I have common
sense that's what Sharon always says
when she's arguing with me but I have
common sense there's some caveats to
what you said there Dave a the wife's
got to be virtuous M and then B the
husband has to his heart has to trust
her yeah so there's let me just tell you
when when we went broke I bought houses
I bought entire apartment complexes that
my wife didn't even know existed ooh we
went to dinner the other night in
Nashville and we're you know these areas
of Nashville that are being
regentrification
this is 35 years ago she never knew we
owned it it's fun but I mean I bought
crap and guess what I went broke
too so now after that and I read that
proverb in my late 20s I'm now in my 60s
and I since then have never again made
major financial decisions without my
wife's input my wife by the way is a
full-time mom with a degree in child and
family
studies
homec okay I run a $300 million business
people All Over America listen to what
Dave Ramsey says about money he checks
with his
wife why because I want no lack of gain
and and I safely trust her I don't want
to mess with Sharon that's all I'm
saying well you don't want that either
there's that hillbilly thing but uh you
know they're highly trained in pots and
pans and I'm not saying just the cooking
part okay
but but the uh yeah I mean it you know
so if you know this why would you go
against the system the system is couples
that work together have high quality
communication quality relationships a
higher probability of ending this thing
together yes not apart and a higher
probability of wealth building there is
nothing in this whole set of data that
tells you to lower the car and buy a
steering wheel right but there is part
of this whole conversation that this is
the thing when you do start combining
your money and when you do say you know
what let's do this thing together it
will Air all the dirty laundry like
it'll show everything in your marriage
that needs help it will show who's
immature it will show who like it'll
start to reveal can't hide Target bags
under the bed anymore and think it's
cute no retail therapy princess yeah you
can't that's not cool yeah it's a girl
thing no it's a stupid thing it's a
little girl thing it's an immature
little girl thing yeah it does I mean
women actually have a backbone walk in
and go look this is what we're buying I
get a vote too yeah but the point is I
don't need to hide stuff from my wife or
her from me the point is you set out you
do set out on a journey where it's like
okay like I thought I could do things my
you can't do everything your way I
thought you know what I'm realizing I
have some trusty like you start to
realize these things about yourself
about your spouse and it's fine you have
to continue to go through through that
Journey so that you can do this thing
and you're doing it together and it's
something that's bringing you together
as opposed to well I try to share my
finances with him and he's just like
this and like no you have to walk
through it have go means that you have
to deal with it that's part of it that's
part of getting the get marriage act
together getting your money act together
it's part of the deal and so God it's
it's it's here's the thing it's harder
but it's easier yes I get that it's
harder because I have to I can't just do
whatever I want to do right I have to
actually work with someone else and come
to agreement that this is good for the
greater hole called the Ramsay right not
just what little Davey wants little
Davey wants a car little Davey wants a
new bass boat those bass are out running
me I need a bigger motor little Davey
you know I mean I'm serious cuz here's
the thing here's the funny part about
this Larry briquette used to talk about
this
when women go
crazy they buy an expensive purse when a
guy goes crazy he buys a
$35,000 thingy with an engine in it of
some kind a side by side
a 18wheeler a I don't know a all the
things I've bought over time I've bought
them all because four wheelers five
wheelers eight wheelers no wheelers
boats you know what I'm saying dropped
30k she drops 300 you know what I'm with
that yes guys you y'all you have
expensive we go big and stupid on the
impulse we go big big yeah I'm with that
I'm with that by and large I mean and
then go honey look what I did you know I
get that I hope we can afford this cuz I
just bought it you know oh my God no no
no no no so here's the thing two
grown-ups learning the difficult process
of learning to work together and loving
the other one so much that I actually
will listen to them causing us to be in
concert where the music is beautiful is
the highest probability of a fabulous
marriage ending up married together at
the end and becoming wealthy yeah very
few people in our data became wealthy in
spite of their stupid spouse right right
yeah yeah yeah that who that wouldn't
play that did whatever they wanted to do
and we have separate accounts because I
believe in Independence you shouldn't
have got married if you believe in
Independence cuz it's not really good
for your marriage this Independence
thing look I have rights yeah I didn't
say you didn't have
rights you know but you know for in
sickness and in health for rich or for
poor unto thee all my worldly Goods I
pledge if Sam warshaw walked up in here
and said I'm going to keep my money
separate from you I want my own account
you would never see him again I'm just
telling you you would never you would
never see him again Dave Wa that's
pretty hardcore never find the body I'm
just saying that I would take a duck
tape and baseball bats involved I don't
want to know here I take off fense to
that if I'm with a spouse I've had your
D gum babies and you're saying you don't
want to share
money oo I have a problem with that
don't come in my bed don't come don't
even come in there wa don't do it and
don't Dave don't give me want to share
some things but not others exactly it
doesn't make sense you have to think
about this it doesn't make sense these
things that you'll share and then
suddenly it's you can't have it all or
nothing right when you when you do
marriage you go all the way in you can't
say 90% but not 10% because and the
preacher says and now you are one one
not and now you are a joint venture he
doesn't pronounce you a joint venture
that's right where we sort of kind of do
this thing sort
of we're going to we're going to share a
bed but not the mayonnaise yeah not the
mustard that's your mustard cuz we're
roommates sort of kind of doesn't work
on much you can't sort of kind of
remember roommates in college did you
ever you ever fight over the M like you
used my mustard yeah that's how stupid
this it's dumb yeah it's just dumb so
all you little people out there that get
all upset when we do this stuff that was
your queue
yeah it's dumb this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsey Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsey Network app in your
favorite app store
[Music]
today live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade washaw
Ramsey personality is my co-host today8
8255 225 is the phone number jet is in
Phoenix hi jet welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi how you doing Dave better than I
deserve what's up hey not much hey we've
been doing all the baby steps gosh as
long as I can remember I'm 25 now the
only one we're not on is Step six um
because we don't have a home I recently
got married and kind of told my wife
we're going to rent for a couple of
years save some money to put a down
payment on a house and wave the
PMI uh been very blessed recently she
got a new job I got a huge new job and
our household income has doubled it's
not tripled right
now way to go it's a blessing it really
is a blessing um but my question for you
you know we were looking in the house
range of 300400
and now with this huge promotion we have
our lease ending in two months do we
sign another lease save up another you
know1 $200,000 and now jump into the
housing range of 700 to800 and see what
the interests are doing um and so I just
don't know hey is it better to just get
in the housing market now get a $300
$400,000 house or wait another year
where you can put 20 25 30% down on a
house and get a bigger house that we've
been wanting that we're going to fill
children with and our dog will finally
have a yard is kind of the question I
have for you kind of the housing market
and what you see happening I don't think
either plan is
bad I think it's just a matter of
personal preference
MH right so you buy the 300 what's going
to happen is in two years you're going
to sell it and move up
yeah which is fine you'll make money on
it you'll make money on I mean Phoenix
is a wonderful
Market it is I'm competing with a lot of
people coming to Phoenix from the web
you'll be all right have a lot more
money than I do you'll be all right
you're 25 did you say did you say you
already have kids or you will have kids
well we're we're starting to look to
have kids um if the Lord provides that
then awesome but I really want to get a
house she really wants to get a house
before we start trying to have kids um
and the little ones don't take up much
room so especially in the beginning
they're like this big yeah they're tiny
so when they come out they're little so
the only thing I thought of off the top
is just moving is a pain in the butt so
you're thinking okay I'm moving from
this house to that house and then that
house to the next house moving is a pain
it's kind of expensive that was the
first thought I had but I am not afraid
to rent for a year longer and call that
patience I'm not afraid to do that if
I'm you mhm I have done that so I know
I'm not afraid to do it okay I'm also
not afraid to jump in buy something and
U you know plan on Flipping it flipping
out of it and moving up a notch two or
three years from now
so either one is fine it's a matter of
whether you like Jade said I hate moving
but I mean I grew up with a real estate
my parents of real estate business our
when I was a kid our furniture was
trained to jump on the truck so um you
know we moved all the time right so it
was just part of it in real estate
people trade houses like nothing so um
you know uh you can do that or if you
hate moving and you really want to sit
there and go I got this very specific
thing what does your wife want to
do you know listening to you guys
especially the last segment she's very
trusting in me in this situation um we
we've
been we don't mind the renting um we
would love to be in a house she's ready
to be in the house I'm ready to be in a
house of these two choices what does
your wife want to
do she's I don't I really think that
she's fine either way I think she's
ready to get into a house is where I
think she is not telling me that she is
why don't you ask her oh I have she's
like J whatever you want to do I know
that's not an answer ask her to pick
yeah whatever you want to do is I'm
going to bring it up later if you do it
wrong I don't want to go with that one
okay now whatever whatever I want to do
is what what I want to do is I want you
to say it out loud and then we'll
discuss whether we do what you want to
do let's that's okay you know I mean ask
her cuz I mean when I get Sharon
actually doing that called talking the
problem through uh that's when I get
gold in the relationship and I get gold
in the financial wisdom of working
together as a married couple but yeah
she was the worst in the first seven
years we were married man she's like
whatever you want to do honey which is
Southern for later I'm going to kill you
you know I mean it's like whatever you
want to do honey you know it's like oh
God you're killing me with this passive
aggressive stuff right so yeah but that
was the first seven years of our
marriage and then I went and did some I
went and did whatever I wanted to do I
thought I thought she meant it oo didn't
mean it I found out later it's like you
know what's wrong with you nothing see
she didn't mean that either there was
something you know that's why you threw
a pan across that dadgum thing anyway
all right Jacob is with us Jacob is in
Nashville hi Jacob how are
you hey I'm doing fantastic how are you
guys we're having way too much fun and
getting paid what's
up that's great to hear Hey U I have a
long time listener this my first time
talking to you and um I have uh heard
you guys discuss this with folks that
are a little older than me um but I'm in
my in my 20s and I'm asking about uh
buying a toy uh specifically a a play
car cool what is it and just a well I
haven't ironed it down yet but I like
muscle cars yeah like which one like
what's your favorite two what's your
favorite
two uh either Mustang or Camaro not
necessarily a Ford or a Chevy guy um
like a 60s vintage like better or 70s
more newer newer like new Camaros okay
yes yeah like a 5 or yeah wow okay cool
all right so what's that what's that
thing run how much you know buying use
not new and um thinking in the 30 to 40
range okay and and what do you
make so a married household income no
kids uh we're between 150 and 200 a year
okay and how much money do you have
uh 40 right at 40 um uh for the past
four or five years
$40,000 uh yes sir that's all the money
you have in the world oh no no no sir no
just set aside for the I said how much
money do you have not not for the car
total how much money do you have okay um
probably between 0 and 90 is that
including an emergency fun like do you
have do you have three to six months of
emergency set aside
yes so that's that includes the
emergency fund and then we've got a
little extra liquid cash and then I have
a car fund that has 40,000 in it got it
okay number one rule for toys is pay
cash okay yes sir those toys they don't
matter number two rule is I use the burn
it in the middle of the living room
floor rule okay if I take that much
money and I burn it in the fireplace
tonight
$40,000 I'm going to burn it in the
fireplace
does my life
change in your case I mean that would be
an
ouchie that would hurt if you if you've
got $100 million it's not an ouchie mhm
right you don't notice it's like buying
a biscuit yeah right for sure so that's
the rule I use I think your I don't
think yours passes that test I think I
think it' take your breath away if you
burned up
40K and because that's what I mean
that's what a toy is you're just just
poof yeah the money's not gone you can s
with a car again I don't mean that but
it it that tells you if you're putting
too much money
in uh things that don't matter yeah I
yeah I I think you're over the line on
that that's what it smells like to me
you do what you want to do but that's
how I measure
[Music]
it
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Gray's with us in
Cookville Tennessee hi gray how are
you hey guys it's a pleasure to speak
with you how are you better than I
deserve how can we help good
uh so about a month ago uh I learned
that my mom actually passed away uh
suddenly and I'm
sorry I is but my my dad's still alive
so uh I've never had to be in this
situation before I'm the oldest brother
out of two and um so I'm kind of taking
care of everything um she has a car uh
that still has uh a loan on it um and I
Kelly Blue B the value uh she's upside
down in it so um I still have possession
of the car but um I'm kind of lost as to
where to go from here stop second I'm
sorry how old was your
mom she was 5 54 I'm sorry turn 54 I'm
sorry what happened to
her um don't really know I just kind of
they found her found her
asleep okay and uh she and your dad
aren't
together correct okay so she was a
single lady divorced and you're her
you're her oldest son and so you'll be
taking care of the estate but there was
no
will correct and she doesn't have a lot
the car was pretty much the only major
asset that she had up in just some small
accounts here and there so no property
or anything like that um all right here
here's the thing when you pass away what
you
own stands good for what you
owe what assets minus liabilities is
called net worth with what you've
described to me the car is upside down
more than all the other things that your
mom owned so she had a negative net
worth does that make
sense yeah I I haven't gotten uh any
information on any accounts that she has
as far as death benefits U life
insurance or anything like that life
insurance is not included in the
equation okay gotcha but the but I mean
so what is on the
car uh about 12,000 and what is it
worth about nine or 10 okay so it's
$3,000 upside down we'll say okay does
she have more than $3,000 of assets
anywhere else in accounts or anything
else do you think uh no I don't think
she does either it would be close if so
yeah I don't think she does either so
here here's the thing you don't have an
estate to sell settle you do not owe any
money her estate has to stand good for
what she has and so there's not if there
was a $10,000 CD before you could put
that in you or your brother's Pockets
you'd have to cover the deficit on the
car the hole in the car but there's not
a $10,000 CD so what this means is the
bank gets the
car and that's all they get so call them
and tell them to come get it and give
them a copy of the death certificate
you can order that from the state and it
takes about two weeks to get the death
certificate in but you can just tell
them what's going on okay there's no
will the lady died without a will that
means intestate without a will in the
state of Tennessee which is where you
are and there's no assets she doesn't
have anything and so you can have the
car you need to take the car back folks
because it's all you're going to get and
no one is going to pay you the balance
on the loan different because no one is
liable mhm okay so is it is a local bank
or do you
know um I think it's uh I think no it's
not it's corporate okay all right I just
holler try to try to get a phone number
on I'm tell them what's going on say I'm
trying to do the honorable thing how's
the easiest way I can get you the car
because there's no assets in this estate
there's no estate going to be probated
there is zero and so but I but no one's
going to pay for the car no one pays
$122,000 for $9,000 not a car so you
guys need to come get it you're not
liable for it you understand me gray mm
I understand okay you don't pay do not
pay a payment do not pay any insurance
do not renew the tags do not put any of
your money in this black
hole whatever money you put into this is
gone don't do it just tell them to come
get the car and and and you know if they
want some help it just to make it easy
we'll get them a copy of the death
certificate so they know what's going on
but that's all there is don't but you
don't need to hire an attorney you don't
need to do anything it's just done it's
sad I'm so sorry I'm sorry the bad
that's the bad news the good news is you
don't have to do anything yeah there's
no big rig oraro you know there's no big
probate court hearing and trying to
figure it out with your brothers because
there's $6,000 we have to try to figure
out how to split up or something good
Lord thank you would have spent almost
all more you spent more time on that
than it was worth cuz the it's great
news that that there's nothing you have
to do except just get you know get rid
of the car and let people know where
they can come get it and please don't
spend any of your money on this you are
under no moral or legal or financial
obligation to take care of any of this
you're letting the folks that have the
car loan know where the car is is a
courtesy on your part and that's the
extent of it otherwise if he did not do
that they would have to basically track
this down on their own yeah they just
have to come try to find the car but
it's going to be sitting somewhere where
the tires go down and and somebody's
going to tow it and it's going to end up
in some impound lot or whatever I mean
it's just going to disappear into the
ether you know into the nothingness that
is our world yeah but yeah um sad so
yeah that's horrible yeah so it's really
good folks for you to remember out there
if um you're dealing with an estate uh
because people get this stuff screwed up
all the time like Dad had credit cards
in his name you're not liable for those
people think they have to pay for it
yeah you're not liable for those but he
had a paid for $660,000
car oh well now now the car has to be
sold to pay the credit cards oh we want
to keep the car well then you're going
to pay then you're going to pay the
credit cards because the assets have to
stand good for the debts that's how that
works you can't just take the assets and
let the debts be you can't it's not how
it works but in his in Gray's case
there's just not any not enough assets
to cover the debts yeah that's the whole
process so ouch that's tough
ouch wow all right Adam is in San
Antonio hi Adam welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so I've got a little bit
of land and I'm looking to put some
light industrial space on it uh you know
those garage doors you roll up at a
small office space inside of it love
um right now uh I've got a total of
225,000 to 23 ,000 uh broken down that's
40K in cash 130k in taxable
non-retirement investment and 55 in raw
my question is do I cash out the taxable
non-retirement or do I sell my house to
be able to pay for this construction to
go into place because my mentality is
the housing market went up in 2022 I'm
sitting on a 3.75% interest rate I don't
think we're going to have a giant jump
in rates in homes any anytime soon but
my accounts they're still not where they
have peaked back uh about a year ago so
I still think there's some upward
Mobility on that so just looking for
your Insight you don't sell your
personal residence to do
investing okay I mean I'm a single guy
so an apartment wouldn't break me um I
know but you're being you're you're
pushing it too far you you need to keep
your Investments separate from your just
cuz you're single doesn't mean you don't
need to keep your Investments separate
from your personal and so you know yeah
I mean you could build an apartment over
the top of one of those rollups and go
live in it that's a cool idea if you
want to do that but I wouldn't do that
no I wouldn't either oh I I would just
uh uh I mean you you can put up a
building for
140 no no I've got the other cash and
then um I've got some funds for this I'm
sorry you just told us all the funds you
had I've got another investor getting in
on it this is my
house okay no this is different you own
the ground you don't need a
partner slow your butt
down you are you are going at a 100
miles hour you're going to run in the
wall man Slow Down slow down it's okay
you got plenty of time how old are you
32 yeah yesterday you're going to be
okay you're going to be okay yeah so
what's it take to build the
building uh uh I was going to phase it
and so we were going to do what's phase
one phase one is going to be one build
five units um with a slab how much and
sing Road getting to it so
[Music]
about you're not ready you're not you're
not ready you're not ready you don't
know your numbers either so that's
another reason you're not ready no you
don't bring in Partners the only ship
that won't sell is a partnership you're
going to get yourself in a mess dude
don't do that slow down don't sell your
house you got time to do this do it
[Music]
right
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you didn't know you can
come and watch the show happen we're on
the air from 1 to four central time
every day our lobby is a fun experience
you get to see a lot of cool ramsy
things and those of you that are plugged
into this stuff there's a great
bookstore there's free homemade
chocolate chip cookies and free coffee
Yum Yum Yum and see if you people don't
come visit Jade and I have to eat all
those cookies it's a rule so it's
completely free a lot of folks while
they're doing some kind of drive-through
or by Nashville put us on one of their
stops thank you for doing that we get to
meet all of you come out and take a
picture with you and all that kind of
stuff in the lobby also right across the
glass from Jade and I we're looking at
these beautiful people Grant and
Christine are with us standing on the
debt free stage which can only mean one
thing they're debt free
welcome guys welcome good to have you
where do You' all live St Louis Missouri
oh fun cool well welcome to Nashville
and how much debt have you two guys paid
off 288,000 love it how long did that
take about 10 years good for you and
your range of income during that time um
we started out at about 100 um and we're
at 160 this year good for you what do
you guys do for a living I'm a nurse
practitioner mhm and I'm a
psychotherapist private practice very
cool very cool and 10 years 288,000 is
that your house yes
indeed yeah looking at weird
people knocked out the big dog what's
the house worth about 240 about 240 so
the 288 included more than just the
house okay we'll come back to that and
how much is in your nest egg about 1.4
million I hate meeting millionaire look
at you baby step millionair yes inde you
said it with such a straight face too oh
she's she's very calculated she's been
calculating uhuh yeah Grant he's dancing
around but she's been calculating all
right very awesome man way to go guys
she's a free spirit with a
calculator love it so how much of this
money did y'all inherit by the way none
none okay so you're worth 1.4 million MH
no plus the house or that's a total
that's a total total Networth including
the house all right very good so uh what
was the rest of the debt we had 168,000
in Consumer Debt about 110 of it was um
the
house your student loan first yeah our
student loans and then a lot of stupid
with credit cards and cars and yeah
we've all done stupid that's what keeps
me in
business and thank you very much indeed
you guys you're fun all right so what
started this whole journey and how did
you get connected to this Ramsey stuff
to decade ago well we went we were at
church and in the bulletin it said
Financial Peace University and so I
thought cuz our Church's name is peace I
thought it was the pastor offering it so
we went over there and it was you jumped
out on stage on the
videos like this is not what I thought
it was this not what I thought it was
going to be I went in Kicking and
Screaming you know did you your line of
you know I saw the heel marks in the
parking lot yeah that was me that was
you all right gu going to be a stuffed
shirt sitting in front of a wall of
books or something like that you know
suit and tie and when you came out in
jeans and a shirt and I was like okay
this might be okay ah okay I like this
guy all right all right well I used to
come out stuffed shirt but I learned the
lesson over the years that it's not very
relatable so uh I quit doing the stuffed
shirt thing I didn't like it anyway so
all right so how far into the lessons
Grant I mean what lesson were on you
went I think this is going to be okay CU
it wasn't just the jeans at the front I
mean come on you you still were sitting
there with your arms crossed but what
what the first lesson get you or couple
more in or what absolutely I remember
tearing up when I saw the uh the gazelle
you know you got to run you got to run
you know and just that feeling of that's
that's what it takes you know you are
literally running for your life and when
that hit when we had all this student
loan debt we both have graduate degrees
and uh you know that that was when it
really got real yeah well you're in the
psychology world I mean and the psychi
uh what I mean Psychotherapy you know
that transformation does not occur
without a visceral experience true yeah
it require it it's not an intellectual I
think I want to transform no I mean you
got there's stuff has to break you know
and you see it all the time I'm sure in
your in your practice so but you guys
did it I'm so proud of y'all thank you
where you go Heroes how feel to have no
debt of any kind it's phenomenal
fantastic absolutely fantastic I love it
so what was your first what was your
first act after paying off the mortgage
after doing it what what did you do to
celebrate what was that moment we're
here this is it this is pretty much it
yeah okay now you got to upgrade what
are you going to do what are you going
to do that's cool now well now we have a
whole bucket list going okay what's the
first thing on the bucket list I would
love to do an Alaskan cruise yes ma' we
got some Alaska people sitting here yeah
they'll tell you I've done a couple of
them and I'll tell you put the train
ride over to Denali and hang out at
Denali a couple days and go up on the
glaciers that's even better than the
cruising love it we did that on our last
one it's a little expensive but you got
the money that's right that's right oh
I'm excited that's fun very cool very
cool I don't think they call it Denali I
don't anyway I don't forget but it's
whatever it's I can't keep that stuff
straight but way to go guys wa to go
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is I mean you kept
at this 10 years you did this the
appropriate way yeah the first four were
really intense and then like you say we
went intentional with investing and
paying off the house M yeah what's the
keys to getting out of debt planning
talking to each other have to be on the
same team yeah it's our
money and going through Financial Peace
University made you get that connected
up then facilitating it more than a
dozen times oh wow yeah you can't do it
if you're the facilitator I did I
brought it into my practice one time and
made the mistake of putting on Facebook
and stuff like that we had people on the
stairway we had bring in extra chairs
and stuff like that so it's like oh
maybe we probably should find a bigger
venue to do this if we're gonna do this
like this again wow very cool that's
very cool and when you coordinate it
it's motivating for you as well right I
mean there's something about that
absolutely yeah it really reminds you of
all the details that are important yeah
and every time you come back to host a
new class you're further ahead too so
it's like you get to see your progress
over and over that's wonderful so good
guys way it Go seeing that light bulb
come on for people when they're like o I
can do thish who was cheering you on
outside the two of
you lots of family and friends were a
little bit Nays but they like you know
once she sets her mind to anything she's
going to do it so they knew I didn't
have a choice they're like watch watch
watch Christine's dust exactly here we
go exactly and our grandson Gavin uh
when we would be driving him around to
get him to take a nap he's in the back
seat out cold and at the end of the
death free scream you'd see him come
alive from the back seat yeah y y yay so
just remembering that that face on a
2-year-old that's so perfect oh that's
great way to go you guys hey we've got
the live and give box for you it's got
the baby steps millionaires book in it
uh which you guys are there way to go
ding ding baby steps millionaires I love
it and of course The Total Money
Makeover book as well you'll be able to
give that to one of the folks that needs
some help that you'll run into and a
Financial Peace University membership
also something you'll probably give away
I suspect but that's the live and give
box and our way of saying thanks and and
saying we're proud of you very cool look
at you man you just did it you just did
it that's so fun how old are you
too I will be 65 next summer right and
she's not okay that's a great answer
she's not even 68 that's a great answer
well played well played you got me out
of that Grant and Christine St Louis
Missouri
88,000 paid off in 10 years making 100
to 160 baby step millionaire in it did
it baby count it down let's hear a debt
free scream go ahead 3 2 1 we're debt
[Applause]
free yeah
baby
yeah that's how that happened I just saw
it love it wow I love that story this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
our scripture of the day Isaiah 5811 the
Lord will guide you always he will
satisfy your needs in a sun-scorched
land and will strengthen your frame you
will be like a well-watered garden like
a spring whose Waters never fail Mary K
Ash says for every failure there's is an
alternative course of action you just
have to find it when you come to a
roadblock take a detour I'm
in uh Angelo is with us in Fairbanks
Alaska hi Angelo how are you I'm doing
great how are youall doing today better
than we deserve what's up in your
world uh I'm calling because me and my
wife have a question for y'all uh I'm 20
she's 21 we both work
full-time we've been wanting to have
kids for a while now something we're
super excited to we're super excited to
be parents how old are you uh I'm 20 and
she's 21
okay but I've been having some concerns
about it because I realize that having
two full-time incomes right now is
pretty sweet and it makes paying the
bills a lot easier uh once we have a kid
if she we agreed she' be a stay-at-home
mom and it is something we could
definitely afford no problem but I'm
concerned because it would slow down
some of our financial goals that we want
to do great trade make the trade make
the trade best thing on the planet is
babies okay we so we've just been
worried because I know it's kind of
weird for people this young to be
excited about having kids yeah uh I
don't know who you're running around
with but um I mean I mean your life is
going to look different and that's okay
I mean she's going to be at home you're
going to go down income you've done the
math you've looked at it I think that
maybe more so than the numbers I think
you're getting your head around how your
life in general is going to look and how
things do had if your wife had a baby
and she's 21 or 22 years old she's going
to be the youngest room mother over at
the elementary school the coolest
youngest room mother ever yeah I mean
yeah and the others will be a decade
older than her that'd be awesome you
know so yeah have at it I mean you do
whatever you want to do dude but I'm
just telling you I if you're going to
trade money for something the best thing
you trade money for is
babies it is a trade it is a trade I've
been over analyzing it I guess now no
you're not over analyzing it you're just
analyzing it but I'm just telling you
it's it's a value based judgment is what
it is on one side of the scales baby
other side of the scales some money yeah
which one tips the scales baby and also
I mean Ian we have a bunch of positives
that come out of it from it too like my
wife she's going to college right now
and she'd be able to you know do more
College work and get her degree faster
so she could boost income once she does
come back to
work yeah yeah what do you
make uh so I'm active duty Air Force uh
so my pay is a little weird after my
housing allowance and my food and all
that good stuff is taken out my
retirement I make 1,500 a
paycheck yeah but all that other stuff's
worth another couple thousand right I I
think if you include all that it comes
out to like 60k something like that
that's good thanks for your
service you know it's up to you you
there's no har you did nothing wrong if
you said we want to Stack cash high
before babies but you did nothing wrong
if you said we want to start our family
while we're
younger and uh we're going to stack cash
a little more slowly because babies are
here there is nothing wrong with either
one of those answers nothing improper it
is a value-based decision absolutely and
um I just as we look back the best
things we ever did were babies
the next actually the best thing was if
I had have known how great grandkids
were going to be I'd have been nicer to
their parents but
um yeah that's grandbabies are the best
cuz if one of them's broken you just
hand it back this one's apparently
broken it smells you you need to take
this one you know so uh yeah I I don't
know what to do with that that's a that
looks like looks like Rachel needs to
fix that so that's a good discussion
because it it is very based on your
values it's based on what you want to do
as a couple cuz Sam and I we had so much
Deb it was like we couldn't fathom
starting a family in that place so we
were like you waited do you until you
got out for your kids didn't we were
married 10 years before we had kids okay
yeah paid off all our debt first but
that's not to say that somebody else
would ever have to think to do that you
know what I'm saying it's really he's
not in debt he's just saying I'm going
to take less wealth yeah exactly I'm
have less income uh that's a little
different than a little different well
it weighs heavier on you I think the
debt does yes absolutely I mean I'm
going to get wealthy slower is different
than I'm overwhelmed with debt right
yeah not to but I mean you could be a
couple and you're in whatever amount of
dead and you could still choose to have
kids yeah you could you could could good
yeah yeah it that's my point there's not
a wrong choice it's like never have
children always have no it's neither one
neither one right but uh it's just my
personal experience is um that the best
thing I've ever done I've done a lot of
fun stuff in my life done a lot of stuff
of note but uh the three Ramsey kids are
the best things I've ever done I feel
that so I second that sentiment there we
go all right Lee is in lck Texas what's
up Lee hey doing well how are you better
than I deserve how can we
help okay so my wife and I we are we're
getting ready to pay our house off in
the next couple months um I make base
salary 60,000 she makes 50 um but then
at the end of every year my bonus will
be anywhere from 100 to
130,000 and so what we're wanting to try
to figure out how to do is now that
we're getting ready to pay our house off
um we want to start trying to max out
our 401ks and Roth IRAs but once we if
we were to completely Max our 40K 401ks
and our IRAs out um that would leave it
a very slim margin to live off of before
the bonus comes in and I'm just kind of
wondering your advice do it out of the
bonus yeah can you lump some it out of
at the end of the no no no no no the
401K is a is payroll withheld and you
don't own the company right exactly Y
and so I can't my bonus pay can't go
towards the 401K I guess can but it
would just be late in the year before it
got there you can have the same
percentage of your bonus going in the
401K if you do the rest and add it up to
where you get to the 19,000 or 28,000 or
whatever it is right
now oh yeah your bonus you can have for
bonus go to 401K it just has to be
payroll
withheld okay so I did not realize that
I talked to our payroll lady and she um
made it sound like I couldn't do that so
well because she doesn't know how to do
it but that doesn't mean it can't be
done yeah gotcha yeah it definitely can
be done because we do it here so I know
it can be done you know we have folks
that that you know they uh and what I do
here in Ramsey which is what I was
leaning towards but you can't do that is
um I just load my 401k out of my first
couple
checks at in January every year and then
I got then I'm done for the year I Max
it out yeah what if what if you did that
so when do you get the bonus well he
can't because he can't control that like
I can like how it's dispersed out I own
it so I can make that happen he has to
just take a percentage of his income
putting into 401K it's the only way
they'll do it and so it's the only way
they're allowed to do it but I'm I'm not
doing anything illegal but I'm saying
because I own it I can choose to fully
fund mine early and quickly um and I've
got the flexibility of you know the
accounting people like work for me and
stuff so that's you know that that that
changes the whole equation versus the
payroll lady that doesn't even know how
to do the deal so um yeah I think you're
probably going to have to just figure
out you got you're making 200 and you
want to put uh whatever your max is in
and figure that out as a percentage of
200 and then just make that the
percentage of your
check okay all the way through and and
then of course we're making sure you got
225s your max so if you made two and a
quarter you'd put two 10% in you follow
me yes I do y but you're gonna have to
also make sure payroll lady gets this
figured out because it'll screw it up if
she screws it up exact yeah I will have
to have a conversation with her okay
yeah yeah but you you can do that it's
just you know you may have to do a
little bit of um uh research and bring
her the actual documentation and showing
her that not only can she do it she
actually has to do it if you ask her to
there you go better yeah so that's the
best play on it yeah and then you can do
that now if you if it's Roth
IRAs you can just load you can load
those on January 1st for the whole year
um and and you can load them on January
1st for the year before as well that's
right yep that's right you the year
before because as long as you file as
long as you put the money in prior to
filing the taxes for the year before you
can can do that and you can also go
ahead and do the next year while you're
at it and just knock it all out and just
max the thing up that's what we do again
we just January is just a big savings
month for the ramies and that's cool
good job Jade well done well done Booth
boys the men in the booth the booth
dudes well played we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus hey what's up guys it's Jade look
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramsy solutions.com and click the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step for you based on
your specific situation that's Ramy
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started